bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir un thriller politique ou
tout est vrai bonsoir Marion vanner
merci d'être là vous signez le piège
Nord Stream aux éditions Les Arènes
c'est une enquête altente sur ce 2 méga
gazoduc dans la Baltique piège
diabolique que nous attendus Poutine
nous européen piège à l'origine même de
la guerre en Ukraine ça mérite une
explication on va en parler longuement
tout à l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
la revente à perte des carburants
va-t-elle faire Piet l'opération du
gouvernement tournait manifestement ou
fiasco tous les distributeurs
auditionnés à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
s'y oppose l'idée est-elle déjà mornée
on en parle dans un instant avec nos
invités et puis vos rendez-vous les
affranchis nos parties pris ce soir
Yannis roder et ses histoires d'école et
puis le regard de l'Europe le regard
européen de Richard Berly bien sûr enfin
Bourbon Express c'est soit signé par Sté
Phanie Despierres voilà donc pour le
programme on y va Marion van hot again
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
en France on n'a pas de pétrole mais on
a des idées et si la formule des années
70 n'était cette fois pas vérifié que
s'est-il passé pour qu'à peine annoncer
par le gouvernement l'opération revente
à perdre des carburants suscite un tel
tollé et puis plus largement comment
contenir les préalable quand les caisses
de l'État sont vides bonsoir David et
Daniel bonsoir et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de Paris ancien
conseiller d'Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée
vous débattez ce soir avec Julien Audoux
le bonsoir bienvenue députés
rassemblement national de l'Yonne et
porte-parole du RN bonsoir Jean-Louis
chilanski ravi de vous accueillir vous
êtes l'ancien président de l'Union
française des industriels pétrolières et
bonsoir Jean-Marc Daniel bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver économiste professeur
émérite à l'ESCP Business School et
éditorialiste aux échos et à BFM
Business voilà pour le les présentations
évidemment c'est c'est un sujet sur
l'énergie c'est pas votre sujet mais
quand même tout ça c'est forcément lié à
la Russie et au cœur de votre ligne
n'hésitez pas à Mario vendredergama a
interrogé nos invités dans ce débat on
commence par les fait que s'est-il passé
donc qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
mesure c'est le chrono de Blacko pour
commencer on l'accueille tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors cette revente à
perte des carburants alors ce soir on
commence par une devinette qui se
souvient combien coûtait un litre de
carburant il y a 5 ans je vous laisse un
peu fouillis d'un beau souvenir mais
bien sûr j'ai la réponse regardez en
octobre 2018 le gazole battait un record
pour la première fois il dépassait la
barre des 1,50 € et un mois plus tard
c'était le début du mouvement des gilets
jaunes justement liés à cette hausse des
carburants donc forcément il y a une
inquiétude légitime pour le gouvernement
quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui c'est à peu
près 30% plus cher qu'il y a 5 ans 1,90
pour le gazole 2 euros en gros pour le
super cela dit il y a quand même une
méthode simple efficace et prouvée en
plus pour faire baisser le prix de
l'essence c'est la fameuse ristourne
comme ça a été pratiqué l'an dernier le
problème c'est que ça a coûté environ 8
milliards au budget de l'État or cette
année la priorité de Bruno Le Maire il
l'a répété c'est maîtrise et la dette
donc pas question de retourner à
l'opération ristourne et donc la
nouvelle tactique consiste à mettre la
pression sur les distributeurs d'essence
pour les inciter à faire baisser les
prix sauf que la semaine dernière sur
France Inter il y avait Dominique
chelcher qui est le président des
magasins U qui a dit écoutez
malheureusement nous pour nous c'est
totalement impossible de baisser le prix
de l'essence en écoute j'ai un prix
d'achat je rajoute les taxes toute la
TVA et toutes les taxes un moment je
vais moi-même me retrouver même sans
prendre de marge à plus de 2 euros et je
n'ai pas le droit de vendre à perte je
sais pas ce que vous avez entendu mais
moi quand je l'entends là j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'il est vraiment embêté
quoi ça ça l'embête de pas pouvoir
vendre à perte il aurait tellement envie
de le faire et puis la loi qui
l'interdit c'est dommage non alors casse
la tienne quand la loi n'est pas bonne
qu'est-ce qu'on fait hop on la change
donc Elisabeth borne l'a pris au mot et
dit bien elle a donné une grande
interview dimanche aux Parisiens en
disant puisque certains distributeurs
veulent vendre à perte et bien on va
changer la loi et à partir du 1er
décembre ça sera autorisé pour 6 mois
évidemment ça paraissait plutôt une
l'idée le résultat c'est que la majorité
c'est précipités sur les mettre dans les
médias pour dire faire part de cette
bonne nouvelle aux Français en disant
rien écouté bientôt il y aura des
baisses conséquences sur les carburants
on écoute Pierre Alexandre angla qui
s'est dévoué pour faire la promotion de
l'idée si on va jusqu'à 25 % de
diminution par rapport au prix d'achat
et bien du prix 20 ça peut être jusqu'à
47 centimes d'économiser sur un litre
d'essence pour les Français et les
Français et donc c'est un geste
considérable
une baisse de 50 centimes sur le guide
d'essence mais bon il y a de quoi être
perplexe je vous donne un exemple
prenons les centres Leclerc qui sont le
deuxième distributeur de carburant en
France donc derrière total Leclerc il
distribue 7 milliards de litres
d'essence chaque année donc si sur
chaque filtre d'essence il perdent 50
centimes à la fin de l'année ils ont
perdu 3000h30 donc je sais bien Michel
Édouard Leclerc fait tout pour avoir
l'air sympa mais trois milliards et demi
c'est un peu cher au nom vous croyez pas
pour avoir l'air simple
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça a été la
douche froide puisque ils étaient
audition aujourd'hui devant la
commission économique et les patrons de
la grande distribution ont été clair
voir cinglants pas de question de vendre
à perte on écoute Thierry Cotillard lui
c'est les Mousquetaires la réalité
économique c'est que en fait on aura on
va pas l'utiliser cette cette
possibilité là parce qu'à un moment si
on fait ça on va augmenter le prix des
pâtes donc on n'est pas complètement
cinglé alors vous l'aurez compris ça va
pas se faire aussi simplement c'était
plutôt a priori un coup comme du
gouvernement pour essayer de répondre à
cette question mais la question elle
reste intacte si c'est pas la bonne
solution d'avoir la vente à perte quelle
est la bonne solution pour faire baisser
le prix merci merci Stéphane pour cette
présentation vous attendiez à ça
franchement David Amiel tous les patrons
de la distribution réunissent ce matin
vous disent non on ne le fera pas mais
d'abord je voudrais pas qu'on se trompe
sur les priorités du gouvernement et les
annonces importantes de cette semaine
face à la crise du carburant face à
l'augmentation de l'inflation les deux
choses les plus importantes qu'il faut
faire face à tête crise à court terme
c'est d'augmenter les salaires l'État
fait déjà ce qui dépend de lui c'est le
cas du salaire minimum qui a augmenté
cette reprise c'est le cas des agents
publics et c'est le cas de la conférence
sociale qui doit augmenter les salaires
et à long terme si on veut pas que ces
crises se répètent année après année
parce que c'est pas la première fois
juste là-dessus c'est de mettre en œuvre
la planification écologique énergétique
c'est ce qui a été annoncé lundi
la mesure de la revente à perte c'est
une loi de 1963 vous levez
l'interdiction et vous prenez un mur pas
seulement de l'opposition des
professionnels est-ce que vous y
attendiez
ce qui est très important c'est dans
cette période là de ne s'interdire
justement aucune piste qui puisse aider
les Français sans coûter excessivement
au contribuable et donc aux Français qui
payent leurs impôts on a obtenu des
choses des autres des entreprises des
industriels des pétroliers le
plafonnement a 2 euros du prix dans les
stations Total énergie la baisse de 5000
références dans les supermarchés par les
industries de l'agroalimentaire et les
supermarchés et effectivement nous
avions entendu ces industriels vous en
métier quelques-uns à la télévision qui
nous disait alors on peut pas baisser
les prix on peut pas suivre ce que fait
total parce qu'on ne peut pas vendre à
perte et bien ce que le gouvernement a
voulu répondre c'est chiche casteln
tiennent si c'est vraiment ça qui vous
gêne nous sommes tout à fait prêts à
retenir
l'alpha et l'oméga loin de là notre
politique mais c'est de pouvoir mettre
ces entreprises qui nous interpellaient
sur cette question là face aussi à leur
contradiction et je dois vous dire vous
reparlier ce que les entreprises de la
grande distribution avaient pu dire ce
matin moi je suis assez gêné de voir des
entreprises sortir l'écrou évidemment
quand le projet de loi arrive nous dire
que c'est absolument impossible
exactement alors même que certaines
d'entre elles ont procédé par exemple
cette année à des rachats d'actions très
importants c'est à dire qu'elles ont
utilisé le cache dont elle disposait non
pas pour investir dans l'avenir de leur
entreprise non pas pour augmenter les
salaires de leur salarié non pas pour
baisser les prix pour les consommateurs
mais pour faire augmenter la
valorisation boursière de leur
entreprise et c'est pour ça que c'était
aussi une des annonces qui a été faite
par le gouvernement cette semaine par la
bouche notamment de Thomas Cazenave
suite d'ailleurs à ce que le président
de la République du temps que nous
souhaitons encadrer beaucoup plus
fermement les rachats d'action bon bah
vous les pointez du doigt très
clairement ce soir dont à vous allez me
dire tout le mal que vous pensez de
cette mesure Julien ou double mais
d'abord sur la grande distribution au
rassemblement national vous exigez
régulièrement des efforts de leur part
vous comprenez qui disent non comme ça
ah je comprends tout à fait qu'il soit
révulsé par cette idée grotesque une de
plus du gouvernement qui est
véritablement une fabrique à idée
saugrenue et surtout à idées qui méprise
le pouvoir d'achat des Français parce
que face à cela on a aujourd'hui des
millions compatriotes qui ont besoin de
la voiture pour aller travailler qui
souffrent de l'inflation qui souffre
d'un prix de l'essence qui aujourd'hui
délirant et affolant j'ai fait le plein
de diesel dans mon département de
l'Yonne j'étais un 94 le litre et vous
avez aujourd'hui non mais c'est très
important c'est très important
le gouvernement ne veut pas actionner le
levier fiscal le seul le seul moyen de
baisser concrètement rapidement
efficacement et de manière pérenne le
prix des carburants et j'adire le prix
des énergies électriques
c'est la baisse de la TVA
ne veut jamais actionner le gouvernement
qui ne veut jamais rendre de l'argent il
veut toujours que ce soit les
distributeurs il veut que ce soit les
consommateurs
on regardera ce que vous proposez dans
le détail je le rappelle de ramener la
TVA à 5 sur le sur le carburant quand
même sur les distributeurs au
rassemblement national souvent vous les
pointez du doigt vous leur dites
attention marge attention c'est très
grave le pouvoir d'achat certains
Français se prive en matière alimentaire
aujourd'hui c'est pareil pour les sens
on se souvient des gilets jaunes je
m'étonne que vous ne leur demandiez pas
un effort au nom de la responsabilité
nationale mais pas avec cette mesure
excusez-moi cette mesure mais je vais
vous donner les clés les effets pervers
d'ailleurs qui ont été très bien très
bien relevés premier effet pervers c'est
ça va engendrer ça engendrerait une
distorsion de concurrence entre les
grandes enseignes celles qui ont les
possibilités justement de vendre à perte
et d'encaisser donc cette cette perte et
puis des indépendants les petites
entreprise notamment dans la ruralité
dans mon département qui vont mettre la
clé sous la porte car elle ne pourront
pas prendre et ensuite et ensuite
deuxième effet pervers ça a été dit
c'est que la vente à perdre sur les
carburants où ils vont rattraper sur les
prix de l'alimentation c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui vous avez des Français qui
n'arrivent pas à faire le plein de
courses qui n'arrivent pas faire le
plein d'essence peut-être qu'il y aura
quelques centimes de moins je dis bien
quelques centimes de moins sur leur
plein de carburant mais en revanche
effectivement le prix des pas de va
augmenter le beurre les œufs etc donc il
ne s'y retrouveront pas Jean-Louis
chilanski on va on va parler déjà des
causes de l'envoler des prix du pétrole
et du baril mais je voudrais quand même
que vous nous commentiez ce qu'a dit
Patrick pouyanet c'était sur quotidien
hier soir il nous dit vous vous est-ce
que vous vendez à perte c'est un censé
enfin un peu de bon sens et il dit 1,99
le litre c'est un plafond je ne
descendrai pas plus bas alors que les
raffineurs font des marges
c'est un autre débat
aujourd'hui
1,99 il est probable que Total commence
à perdre de l'argent sur la distribution
parce que les prises du pétrole on l'a
dit tout à l'heure c'est prête 95
dollars le baril 94 20 je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure et à ce niveau là et ça a
beaucoup augmenté et à ce niveau là
pour le prix du baril au total est
proche de perdre de l'argent sur devant
c'est inconcevable c'est une question
que à mon avis beaucoup de gens se
posent ils ont perdu
de ce que l'année dernière la question
disons donné c'est leur écouter 500
millions
et le marché français pour Total ça
représente environ 550 600 millions
d'euros par an donc ils n'ont rien gagné
sur le marché français l'année dernière
alors maintenant ce débat sur les
profits total on peut en parler autant
que vous voulez c'est sur le brut qu'il
y a une de l'argent
il produisent du pétrole en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient en Amérique dans le monde
entier et sur ce pétrole qu'il
produisent à 90 dollars le baril oui il
gagne de l'argent mais ça c'est
complètement indépendant du marché
français complètement indépendant ce
pétrole ils peuvent le vendre n'importe
où dans le monde à 90 dollars le baril
ils sont aussi dans la distribution en
France pour des raisons historiques et
comme ça l'ensemble du maillage des
autoroutes français mais bien sûr le
pétrole brut ils sont pas seuls ils sont
en concurrence avec BP avec Shell avec
exson et si vous leur enlevez quelque
chose vous leur tapez dans les pieds sur
le sur la culture cette hausse du baril
c'est les pays de l'OPE l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est la Russie c'est l'embargo
sur le gazole
c'est très simple la demande de pétrole
ne cesse d'augmenter
les 100 euros les 50 litres vous voyez
c'est du super 95 et ce sont des sources
Insee ça va ça va continuer à monter
alors ça devrait continuer à monter
parce qu'effectivement le prix du baril
va probablement continuer à monter il
est allé beaucoup plus haut et certaines
époques on parle de Leman Brothers là en
ce moment à l'époque le véritable
problème dépendamment les mains de
Mother c'est que le prix du barils
étaient à 145 dollars le baril et donc
là il y avait une ponction qui était
plus importante sur la richesse l'euro
protégé les Français contre ça un autre
chiffre si vous revenez à 1970 vous
parliez des années 70 en 1970 le SMIC
était à 3,30 et le litre de descend
c'était à un Francis et donc vous aviez
avec une heure de Smic 3 litres
d'essence si on reproche des SMIC à
l'heure actuelle à 11,52 pour avoir le
même rapport il faudrait que le prix de
l'essence soit 3,84 et donc vous allez
pouvoir d'achat le jour le pouvoir
d'achat oui donc normalement si on
gardait le pouvoir d'achat de 197 avant
avant le choc pétrolier on l'aurait à
3,84 qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre
temps il s'est passé effectivement qu'il
y a eu davantage de pouvoir d'achat les
gens ont du mal à se projeter dans le
passé la vraie question qui se pose
c'est effectivement on l'a dit si on
oblige les gens à baisser le prix de
l'essence ils vont le reporter sur
d'autres produits et la question c'est
une responsabilité devant les Français
de le faire est-ce que Carrefour
osera augmentait le prix des pattes on
perd des clients au moment où on vérifie
comme ça chaque produit dans les
supermarchés la question pour le
gouvernement c'est aussi on a parlé de
la planification écologique les
événements des gilets jaunes c'était au
départ sur un refus de la taxe carbone
mais au niveau international nous sommes
systématiquement montrés du doigt pour
notre inertie climatique et donc un des
enjeux c'est est-ce que effectivement on
peut concilier la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le véritable professeur la
fin du mois la fin du monde mais pour
vous pour bien comprendre il y a pas du
tout d'hypocrisie de la grande
distribution la loi du marché rien que
la loi du marché avec ma chérie que la
loi du marché la vocation d'une
entreprise c'est pas de faire des pertes
et donc effectivement je pense des
circonstances exceptionnelles comme
celle qu'on connaît toutes les
circonstances tout le monde est
davantage besoin de pouvoir d'achat ce
qui est intéressant dans cette affaire
vous avez dit c'est chiche je pense que
effectivement quand le responsable de
Super U a dit écoutez baisser des je
peux pas on lui dit bon ben écoutez on
va vous dire que vous allez pouvoir et à
ce moment-là voir ce que vous allez
faire c'est pas facile je ne peux pas
qu'il dit je veux c'est je ne veux pas
ça veut pas dire je veux c'est non non
c'est totalement différent et dernière
remarque la loi de 63 elle était prise
dans un contexte de contrôle des prix et
pourquoi on avait pris cette loi sur
l'interdiction des revendes à perdre
parce que c'était une façon de
d'empêcher au décideurs de Rivoli de
favoriser certains les autorisant à
vendre à perte pour couler la
concurrence et donc on est plus dans une
situation où on est en contrôle des prix
on est dans une situation c'est la
concurrence c'est pas évident la
majorité de défendre cette mesure vous
faites un peu l'unanimité contre vous au
point même que dans la majorité certains
de vos partenaires pour ne pas le nommer
Richard Ramos se réjouit de cette levée
de boucliers écoutez-le
depuis des jours et des jours je dis que
cette idée de permettre à la grande
distribution de la vente à perte c'est
une folie c'était une folie parce que
nos 6000 pompistes de la ruralité
allaient crever ils nous l'ont dit ce
matin leur a fait dire que si il vendait
à perdre de l'essence ils augmenteraient
le prix des pattes et bien je suis
content d'avoir gagné ce combat là avec
mes collègues à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
pour le coup un formidable avocat de la
grande distribution il est un peu moins
désintérêts français parce que à court
terme si on suivait les propositions du
rassemblement national s'aboutirait à
faire tous les ans un chèque de dizaines
de milliards d'euros au distributeur
d'essence en espérant qu'il le répercute
sur les prix des consommateurs ce qui
n'est même pas garanti une dizaine de
milliards d'euros pour que les
téléspectateurs en tête c'est
l'équivalent du budget du ministère de
la Justice qui peut croire que l'État
peut se permettre tous les ans de
dépenser l'équivalent du budget du
ministère de la Justice pour une baisse
de prix en tournée même pas sûr qu'elle
soit répercutée et donc si on ne veut
pas à l'avenir connaître à nouveau ses
crises ce qu'il faut c'est évidemment
pouvoir sortir de la dépendance dans
laquelle on est au gaz et au pétrole
étranger ça a été d'ailleurs très bien
rappelé si on subit aujourd'hui cette
augmentation du prix du baril c'est
parce que les Russes les problèmes oui
mais là aussi je veux dénoncer les
hypocrisies du rassemblement national
parce que c'est vraiment des
souverainistes en carton quand il a
fallu défendre cette électrification de
notre économie pour arrêter justement de
dépendre de ses puissances étrangères il
n'y avait personne du côté du
Rassemblement National Marine Le Pen
pendant la campagne électorale proposait
même de démanteler des éoliennes de
mettre un moratoire sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques vous avez voté contre la
loi sur les énergies renouvelables et
donc vous avez voté pour vous aurez la
dépendance à l'Arabie Saoudite
parce que c'est vrai que vous arguments
sont vides de sens et sont totalement
ridicules déjà sur la baisse de la TVA
vous qui êtes des Européens et
européistes regardez un peu ce qui se
fait à l'étranger regardez un peu ce qui
se fait en Espagne au Portugal pourquoi
pourquoi des États et des gouvernements
dont vous nous dites qu'ils sont des
alliés des partenaires donc reprennent
notre proposition
notre
terminer les prénoms reprennent notre
proposition et très clairement c'est pas
faire un chèque à la grande distribution
baisser la TVA c'est baisser la pression
fiscale c'est rendre du pouvoir d'achat
au ménage c'est leur permettre pas comme
vous le dites c'est pas de l'argent qui
est perdu qui s'évapore c'est de
l'argent qui va être réinjecté dans la
consommation et surtout dans le pouvoir
de vivre parce que à l'heure actuelle on
en est plus au pouvoir d'achat on est au
pouvoir de vivre de Français qui
n'arrivent plus vous êtes déjà soigner
et qui n'arrive même plus à se nourrir
c'est ça la réalité et je constate que
depuis le début et depuis le début de ce
mandat vous avez un gouvernement qui est
totalement sourd et qui ne veut jamais
jamais rendre un centime et et français
ne le comprennent pas parce qu'il faut
savoir que quand même on parle du prix
du brut et du baril c'est bien gentil
sauf que sur un litre d'essence c'est
60% de taxes
alors on y va
comment est construit le prix c'est
l'État qui se gave à chaque augmentation
c'est 60 % de taxes voilà il faut le
savoir et que les Français savent que le
gouvernement ne veut pas rendre de
l'argent simplement je tourne le coup à
ce canard qui circule effectivement de
la part c'est la réalité nationale pour
vous donner les chiffres alors justement
sur la fabrication
de TVA augmentent elles ont augmenté de
2 milliards d'euros mais dans le même
temps l'État a dépensé 8 milliards
d'euros pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
à la pompe des Français c'est le cas de
la riston de
carburants
s'il vous plaît pas cher bravo allez on
va vous montrer un sujet comment il
fabriquait supprimer à ce stade du débat
finalement Poutine se frotte un peu les
mains bien sûr le l'augmentation du prix
du pétrole revient à Poutine aussi et
permet de compenser les sanctions qui
lui ont qui lui sont imposées donc
de nouveau c'est un des grands gagnants
de la conjoncture la guerre de l'énergie
alors comment est fabriqué le prix du
pétrole quelle est la part des taxes que
perçoit l'Etat dans ce prix et que
propose les oppositions pour réussir à
le faire un peu baisser à la pompe
explication avec Marco Polo
des prix qui n'en finissent plus de
flamber en début de semaine le litre 200
plomb 95 coûté en moyenne un euro 97 un
euro 93 pour celui du gazole comment se
décompose le prix de l'essence pour un
litre de sang plomb vendu à 1,93 € le
litre le coût de production est de 80
centimes la distribution représente 20
centimes le reste du prix est composé de
trois taxes comme la TVA ou la ti-cpe
cet axe pèse aujourd'hui 93 centimes
soit 48% du prix total comment baisser
cet axe au rassemblement national on
propose de baisser la TVA de 20 à 5,5%
pour financer le coût de la mesure soit
10 milliards d'euros d'après l'Institut
Montaigne Marine Le Pen veut taxer les
surprofits des groupes pétroliers
mesurent réclamés aussi par la nupes les
nationale totale et que ça ne se gavent
de milliards d'euros de bénéfices pour
arroser leurs actionnaires 18 milliards
en 6 mois pour total 18 milliards en
trois mois pour exson d'autres voies
s'élèvent pour agir sur la TI CPE la
taxe intérieure de consommation sur les
produits énergétiques à une valeur fixe
soit 60 centimes sur un litre mais
Richard Amos député de la majorité
réclame le retour d'une taxe flottante
qui fluctue en fonction des prix
autrement dit si le prix du baril
augmente la taxe diminue pour ne jamais
dépasser un plafond fixé à l'avance
au-delà de 2 euros à la pompe le
consommateur il peut pas y aller et donc
moi je dis qu'à partir du moment où le
prix est au-dessus de 2 euros alors on
enclenche ce plafond là et on arrête de
prendre la taxe sur la TICPE mise en
place par le gouvernement Jospin entre
2000 et 2002 cette taxe flottante pour
écouter plusieurs milliards d'euros à
l'État
alors on va les reprendre une par une
j'ai commencé par les experts que vous
êtes on reviendra aux politiques
aujourd'hui je suis en ski la TVA c'est
vraiment la proposition martelée par le
RN maintenant depuis plusieurs mois on
la ramène à 5,5 c'est autant dans la
poche de contribuable ou pas c'est dans
le déficit de la France
c'est 10 milliards d'euros qui vont
directement dans les visites de la
France et c'est vrai que ce serait
percuterait directement sur les prix
les distributeurs ne gardent ces
mécaniques c'est mécanique la TVA baisse
les prix baisse comme les TICPE c'est
absolument mécanique il y a pas d'autres
mais c'est dix milliards et puis surtout
ça n'est pas ciblé
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde en
profite ceux qui en ont besoin au moins
besoin celui qui va travailler le matin
il va en profiter mais celui qui va
passer ce week-end à nos vies il en
profite aussi donc on a un problème de
ciblage de la mesure de la taxe et puis
la deuxième chose sur la TVA c'est que
c'est irréversible
on peut plus revenir en arrière à partir
du moment vous baissez une taxe comme
celle là revenir en arrière c'est
impossible du point de vue politique et
du point de vue de l'opinion publique
c'est impossible c'est pour ça que ce
gouvernement a toujours compensé de
façon perpétuelle
l'année dernière 18 30 15 parce que ça
on donne une ristourne on augmente on a
diminue c'est le même effet alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que là ce
qu'on voit c'est que la revente à perte
ça va pas faire franchement marcher
peut-être quelques weekends certaines
grandes surfaces le front la TVA trop
cher la TI PPP flottante trop cher
irréversible qu'est-ce qu'on fait oui
par rapport à ça effectivement je pense
qu'il y a trois éléments premièrement on
parle du Portugal et tout ça la
différence entre le Portugal et la
France et que le Portugal dégage des
excédents budgétaires en ce moment et
donc il peut se permettre des choses que
la France ne peut pas se permettre vu
l'état
je rappelle quand même que le Portugal
il y a 10 ans c'était
des moutons noirs de l'Europe c'était le
P de pics c'était des bons il a fait des
effets la situation des finances
publiques aujourd'hui nous l'empêche
comme les finances publiques n'ont pas
été redressés dans les dernières années
on peut pas se permettre ce genre de
choses la deuxième chose c'est que
l'enjeu des Français c'est le pouvoir
d'achat c'est pas uniquement le prix de
l'essence et l'ensemble du pouvoir
d'achat et là je reviendrai sur ce qui a
été dit sur l'évolution des salaires
c'est vrai que si on baisse le prix de
l'essence tout le monde en bénéficie y
compris les gens qui sont présentés
comme étant des riches les propriétaires
de SUV en revanche quand on revalorise
le SMIC ce qui est prévu par la loi et
ce qui a été fait systématiquement
depuis que
je sais pas si c'est suffisamment mais
en tout cas c'est au-delà la règle est
claire au-delà de l'inflation puisque
l'inflation qui est prise en compte est
une inflation spécifique pour les bas
revenus donc c'est au-delà de
l'inflation qui est affichée et
normalement ça tient compte de
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat des
classes les plus défavorisées et donc
comment on le disait baisser le prix de
l'essence tout le monde a le bénéficié
augmenter le SMIC en bénéficie
effectivement des gens qui sont les plus
défavorisés donc je pense que la bonne
mesure c’est de porter vers vers ce
genre de réponse et puis on parlait de
planification écologique il y a quand
même la loi d'orientation des mobilités
qui demandait de lutter contre ce qu'on
appelle l'auto-solisme alors je suis pas
si vous voyez ce mot qui est apparu dans
le discours alors l'auto-solisme ça
c'est un néologisme il y a une trentaine
d'années c'est le fait que les gens le
matin quand ils vont travailler son seul
dans leur voiture et donc la loi
mobilité qui a été votée en 2019 disait
il faut tout faire pour inciter les gens
à faire du covoiturage parce que comme
ça à la fois c'est bon pour la planète
et puis c'est bon pour leur finance
alors un plein divisé par deux ou trois
évidemment dans une voiture c'est moins
cher juste le suffisant il y a des
enquêtes il y a 80% des voitures qui
sont dans des grandes métropoles entre 7
heures et 9h tu ont juste une personne à
bord et donc un des enjeux c'est aussi
de vous parliez de ce qu'on passait dans
les années 70 dans les années 70 il y
avait eu une politique de chasse du
gaspi seulement on avait des idées mais
parmi l'idée il y avait au chassé le
gaspi et pourchasser le gaspi on avait
demandé aux entreprises d'organiser le
covoiturage je pense que des prises de
décision individuelles de cette nature
sont susceptibles de permettre de
répondre à ce problème de
surconsommation des sens c'est les
petits pas en fait hein
il y a pas de mesure miracle regarde nos
finances publiques et de la dette
aujourd'hui l'État a pris sa part mais
il faut quand même un une grande action
face à ces grands chocs et c'est pour ça
que je reviens ce qu'en disant début
d'émission la première chose à faire
face à l'inflation dans le domaine du
pétrole comme dans les eaux dans la
période actuelle c'est d'augmenter les
salaires est-ce que plus que des mesures
ponctuelles qui ont leur utilité on a pu
l'évoquer et à nouveau le cas du
plafonnement de l'essence qu'on a pu
mettre en place dans l'agroalimentaire
salariale est très faible vous avez
raison c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons convoqué une conférence
sociale pour mettre autour de la table
syndicat patronat et état notamment pour
revenir sur ce que vous disiez très
justement c'est à dire la mobilité
salariale pour pouvoir augmenter les de
ces salariés qui restent trop longtemps
scotché au SMIC et augmenter les revenus
c'est ça la réponse à court terme pour
les mois qui viennent C'est ça la vraie
réponse plutôt que les propositions
démagogiques du rassemblement social qui
n’aboutent quelque chose le pays le
comprendra de la dette publique à la
crise de l'inflation
à recevoir de la macronie monsieur
10 milliards de la mesure 10 milliards
d'euros de la justice c'est le résultat
laissez-moi terminer 10 milliards
d'euros c'est des choix politiques c'est
du gaspillage effectivement c'est la
lutte contre la fraude sociale qui n'a
jamais entrepris la preuve sociale je
rappelle que c'est quand même obamo au
minimum entre 15 milliards et jusqu'à 50
milliards d'euros de pertes par an donc
il faut aller chercher cet argent donc
très clairement de l'argent il y en a de
l'argent on en gaspille beaucoup ce
gouvernement gaspille beaucoup il faut
un peu en rendre au français et
concernant la TVA donc effectivement
quand on la baisse on la baisse qu'une
fois mais les produits de première
nécessité que sont aujourd'hui le diesel
et l'essence ils sont vitaux pour les
Français ils sont vitaux pour l'économie
parce que quand vous avez de l'essence à
2 € litres vous avez des Français qui
sont assignés à résidence qui ne vont
plus travailler qui se mettent en arrêt
maladie parce que ça revient trop cher
les charges pour aller travailler sont
aujourd'hui délirantes et donc c'est
toutes l'économie française qui est
plombée donc c'est pour ça que c'est
très important comme le propose de notre
nationale on voit bien que cette TVA
présidentiel mais voilà il a il a bien
déjà commencé Jean-Louis silence qui est
le mot de la fin le gouvernement a
laissé futé ce chiffre de 47 centimes de
moins le litre si cette mesure alors on
voit que ça en prend pas le chemin mais
été appliqué douce dans ce chiffre c'est
une absurdité
nous ne tomberons plus on va en parler
directement pendant 20 ans Vladimir
Poutine a avancé ses pions pour rendre
toute l'Europe accro à son gaz comment
la faute à qui l'élément de réponse dans
lévitation de Marion Becker et on en
parle juste après toutes les deux
si on vous invite Marion vannerait
targame c'est parce que vous venez de
publier une biographie d'un genre
nouveau embrossant le portrait d'un
tuyau qui a empoisonné l'Europe Nord
Stream vous dévoilez à travers lui une
incroyable saga ce piège tendu à
l'Europe par Vladimir Poutine au service
des intérêts économiques et
géopolitiques de la Russie Marion vanner
vous connaissez bien l'Europe centrale
pour y avoir mené différentes enquêtes
journalistes d'investigation
indépendante depuis quelques années
après avoir longtemps collaboré au monde
vous avez reçu le Prix Albert Londres
dans ce polar géopolitique ou grouille
des espions du KGB ou les morts
suspectent se comptent par dizaines ou
le mystère des deux sabotages de North
stream en septembre 2022 reste entier
vous détaillez comment Vladimir Poutine
a tissé son piège pour rendre l'Europe
dépendante et otage du gaz russe grâce à
ces deux immenses gazoducs qui relie la
Russie à l'Allemagne via la mer Baltique
un vrai traquenard dans lequel sont
tombés nos dirigeants complices et
aveugles comme dira Schroeder Angela
Merkel et François Fillon
et avec tous les représentants des pays
européens qui sont ici
nous montrons que nous comptons sur une
relation sûre et de confiance avec la
Russie s'en est même un excellent
exemple
chacun sort donc gagnant de ce
partenariat économique l'inauguration de
ce gazoduc annonçait la funeste guerre
en Ukraine alors on a une question pour
vous Marion vanreterghem aujourd'hui
ont-ils ouvert les yeux et tirez les
leçons de ce piège Nord Stream
réponse
oui et si j'en crois en tout cas les
personnalités allemandes que j'ai
rencontrées au plus haut niveau j'ai
beaucoup parlé avec Angela Merkel qui
qui est un peu incapa part parce qu'elle
ne rentre pas dans toutes les dans les
cases de nid de la corruption ni de la
naïveté dit de la complaisance vraiment
c'est plutôt elle agit en pragmatique
dans la conséquence de l'arrêt du
nucléaire enfin il y a beaucoup à en
dire mais j'ai fait j'ai la complicité
l'aveuglement la cupidité la faiblesse
tout ça c'est derrière nous aujourd'hui
malheureusement je ne pense pas parce
que on a encore le problème chinois qui
se pose et malgré tout on est on est on
a tendance à se prendre au piège des
grandes puissances alors la Chine n'a
pas tendu un piège aussi méthodiquement
pendant de 20 ans comme l'a fait
Vladimir Poutine mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on soit totalement vacciné dans mon
livre j'interview très longuement le
ministre de l'Économie l'ancien ministre
de l'Économie d'anglais américain
social-démoc qui faisait partie de la
coalition Sigmar Gabriel zigmar Gabriel
et qui ça n'était pas mon intention en
allant le voir mais j'étais tellement
frappé par cette interview tellement si
clairvoyante je n'ai jamais vu en France
l'équivalent d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique parlé avec autant de netteté
de son erreur de l'autocritique dans
l'autocritique je dois dire que du coup
j'en ai fait une longue interview dans
le livre parce que là on et il reproduit
un peu finalement ce que m'avait dit
aussi Angela Merkel et d'autres que j'ai
sur le fait qu'il y avait quand même
quelque chose qui n'ont pas vu et c'est
ce qui n'ont pas vu c'était cette
appétit territoriale de Vladimir poutre
alors justement vous parlez l'une des
plus Gigantes l'une des gigantesques les
plus gigantesques erreurs stratégiques
du 21e siècle c'est voilà très fort
comme formule c'est avant tout pour vous
l'erreur de qui est-ce que c'est
l'Occident dans son ensemble de l'Europe
avant tout de l'Allemagne principalement
bonne question je pense que c'est une
erreur extrêmement collective européenne
à l'exception de ceux qui ont vu clair
c'est-à-dire les pays baltes la Pologne
l'Ukraine qui n'était pas encore dans
l'Union européenne les plus coupables ce
sont les plus
ostensiblesment coupables sont les
Allemands parce que c'est une grande
puissance industrielle la première
puissance économique européenne et que
du fait qu'ils ont fait du nucléaire un
tabou c'est une histoire en soi ça la
manière dont ils sont venus au tabou du
nucléaire mais étant une grande
puissance ayant renoncé et la population
dans son ensemble ne voulant pas
entendre parler du nucléaire ne pouvant
pas utiliser le charbon comme il le
voudrait vu les besoins écologiques de
la planète ils se sont rués sur le
gâteau et que l'on il y a le il y a la
solution du gaz russe bon marché donc
eux ce sont les principaux
coupables si l'on peut dire mais les
Français leurraient été autant s'ils
n'avaient pas eu le nucléaire et on ne
peut pas dire que les Français ont
condamné les Allemands et d'ailleurs les
compétences françaises sont présentes
a insisté pour pour cela Nicolas Sarkozy
avait vendu des navires Mistral à la
Russie on peut imaginer si François
Hollande n'avait pas stoppé ces
mistrales il serait parti prenant dans
la guerre contre l'Ukraine on aurait on
serait dans de baudra donc ce que j'ai
dire c'est que c'est les Allemands sont
sont son premier rang mais malgré tout
il y a eu assez collective en dehors des
pays de l'Est qui étaient qui
connaissaient la Russie mieux que les
autres et en dehors des Américains qui
pour des intérêts personnels mais aussi
par lucidité ont toujours alerté le
danger contre cette dépendance qui est
fascinant dans le livre au-delà des
scènes qui sont restituées entre Moscou
Berlin c'est comme si on était présent
c'est que le projet Nord Stream déjà
correspond à l'arrivée de Vladimir
Poutine au pouvoir et vous dites et vous
démontrer que déjà il avait dans la tête
l'Ukraine ça c'est très important que
vous soulignez ça parce qu'en effet ce
qui m'a frappé c'est que en prenant ce
Nord Stream comme un personnage en fait
une espèce de fil conducteur de cette
grande histoire de dépendance entre la
Russie et l'Europe je me suis rendu
compte et à chaque fois j'étais étonné
par les coïncidences de dates que en
fait la durée de vie de North stream
correspond totalement de du début à la
fin parce qu'il est toujours là mais à
la durée de vie de Poutine au pouvoir et
c'est immédiatement après être arrivé au
pouvoir en 2000 en 2000 qu'en 2001
l'idée de Nord Stream est lancé par
Vladimir Poutine alors justement s'y
connaît en matière première et dans le
rôle des matières premières sur une pour
bâtir une grande puissance puisqu'il
avait fait une thèse plagiée mais signée
par lui sur l'importance des matières
premières dans la puissance d'un pays
justement tout commence il y a 20 ans
lors d'un discours restait dans les
mémoires en Allemagne le jeune Poutine
vient d'arriver au pouvoir donc et il
choisit Berlin pour l'une de ses
premières visites à l'étranger on va
l'écouter dans un Allemand quasi parfait
s'adresser aux députés allemands
alors la guerre froide est finie ses
glaçons d'ailleurs quand on connaît la
suite vous racontez ça dans le détail là
c'est l'opération séduction de Poutine
qui fonctionne à merveille oui on voit
il a l'air tout à fait inoffensif il y a
une innovation debout au parlement
allemand les seuls qui sont réservés et
ce le seul parti qui a toujours été
réservé vis-à-vis de la Russie de la
Chine c'est le Parti vert allemand ce
qui est paradoxal c'est que c'est le
parti est très très opposé aux
dictatures à la dépendance à Nord Stream
ils ont toujours sonné l'alarme mais
pour autant c'est cette idéologie
anti-nucléaires qui est le socle du
Parti vert qui a provoqué cette
dépendance au gaz russe donc là il les
verres sont dans une forme de paradoxe
et au premier rang ce discours on est en
2001 juste après d'ailleurs l'attaque du
11 septembre il y a des rares Schroeder
tout sourire chancelier déjà séduit
totalement séduit et au fond le premier
le premier compagnon le plus le plus
investi dans le projet Nord Stream
conscient de toutes ses conséquences
exactement et ce discours donc a lieu en
2003 juste après l'attentat du 11
septembre contre les tours du de
Manhattan ce qui explique aussi une
forme de complicité c'est que tout le
monde est dans le même combat contre
l'islamisme Poutine en a fait une raison
d'être avec sa guerre en Tchétchénie et
il a fauté de faux attentats Moscou en
accusant les tchétches enfin il est dans
une guerre contre l'islamisme là il
rejoint l'Occident et donc tout
l'Occident a-t-on et apprécie l'arrivée
de Vladimir Poutine qui d'autant plus
qu'il tranche avec le président son
prédécesseur boricelsin qui faisait peur
à tout le monde parce que c'était un
gros Soulard qui dansait sur les tables
que il avait l'air de son pays était en
véritable chaos il avait certes assuré
la transition démocratique mais tout le
monde avait peur de ce qui était en
train de devenir la Russie et donc
Poutine arrive comme une espèce de
d'espoir et et garde Schroder qui est
déjà séduit on le voit dans cette scène
au Bundes a déjà commencé à négocier
avec lui cette affaire Nord Stream c'est
déjà en germe dans leur tête c'est déjà
dans les tuyaux il va être propulsé à la
tête du consortium Nord Stream
âgé juste après son son départ de la de
la Chancellerie d'ailleurs l'enquête est
accablante pour lui mais pour beaucoup
beaucoup de dirigeants et notamment de
chefs d'entreprise du milieu économique
vous parlez de la Nord Stream connection
en Allemagne pour ce figurer les choses
je vais vous montrer le siège à
Saint-Pétersbourg de Gazprom leader
mondial du gaz c'est donc évidemment
dans la ville de Vladimir Poutine
qu'est-ce qu'elle symbolise cette image
alors c'est on pense tous à une give à
une ogive nucléaire ça n'est pas un
hasard c'est un monument c'est je crois
que c'est une des plus grandes des tours
les plus hautes du monde évidemment
Poutine a fait dans le gigantisme ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que donc
Poutine a voulu symboliser la puissance
de la Russie par cette tour de gaz Prom
qui est comme vous le rappeliez le plus
grand groupe gazier mondial pour le plus
grand producteur de gaz le plus grand
distributeur de gaz et ce qui n'est pas
hasard non plus c'est que Poutine a
déplacé le siège de Gazprom qui était
préalablement à Moscou vers
Saint-Pétersbourg et la ville de
Saint-Pétersbourg pour Poutine c'est
très important d'abord bon allez au bord
de la de la Baltique donc c'est de là
que va partir Nord Stream mais c'est
surtout la ville de son éducation
c'était il est né lui à Lénine grade et
il a eu deux référents deux écoles qui
étaient les venaient d'un milieu très
pauvre il fallait se démener et survivre
dans un une un milieu extrêmement
difficile sous l'airbré Genève qui était
une ville tenue par les mafia et son
école ça a été d'abord les chefs mafieux
auxquels il a réussi à justement à
s'intégrer avec plutôt brio et l'autre
école c'était le KGB et tout ça c'est sa
formation c'est sa ville natale et sont
toute sa bande d'amis qu'on appelait la
bande de Peter Saint-Pétersbourg qui
sont d'ailleurs
incroyablesment les à la bande du KGB la
bande de Petersbourg in probablement
reclasser
recaser dans Gazprom dans Nord Stream on
retrouve tous les anciens espions du KGB
c'est passionnant vous n'avez pas
rencontré garage
elle va lancer enfin elle va inaugurer
on a tous les images on les a vu dans le
sujet le grand projet Nord Stream après
l'annexion de la Crimée comment c'est
possible que j'appelle dans mon livre
l'année de la honte c'est 2014 qui est
donc l'année de l'invasion de la Crimée
et là il y a quand même une faiblesse
coupable alors là c'est pas seulement
les Allemands c'est vraiment tout
l'Occident y compris les États-Unis on
condamne par des sanctions mais on est
face à quelqu'un qui très clairement
nous montre déjà il y avait mille
manières de le savoir et de le percevoir
et des journalistes ont alerté encore
une fois les pays de l'Est ont alerté
sur le fait que Poutine dès son arrivée
au pouvoir à un plan un plan d'expansion
territoriale le la strat le l'objectif
de Poutine qui est au fond assez clair
très vite c'est de reconstituer les
frontières de l'Union soviétique dont il
a dit que la chute et le déclin était la
catastrophe la plus grande catastrophe
du XXe siècle ça il l'a dit écrit et il
veut récupérer ses propres frontières et
en tout premier lieu l'Ukraine est une
forme d'obsession chez lui en
particulier depuis 2005 et les révolus
2004 2005 et les révolutions la
Révolution orange et il veut donc
récupérer cet empire et il prend des
petits bouts il avance pas à pas la il
ne comprend que la force dès qu'il voit
une signe de faiblesse il prend un bout
de la Géorgie il prend sur de l'Ukraine
il prend sa principale arme donc on
revient l'indépendant il met de 2014 où
là il fait un pas de plus et
l'Occident s'écrase plus ou moins mais
comme il y a aussi les incidents dans le
bomba c'est des milliers de morts il y a
ces accords de Minsk c'est des
négociations de mins qui commencent avec
le président français Hollande la
chancelière Merkel le président
ukrainien pourchenko et Vladimir Poutine
pour essayer de faire cesser ses combats
et là tout se brouille est-ce que
m'avait expliqué Angela Merkel c'était
qu'on ne peut pas au moment où on
commence une négociation avec quelqu'un
pour essayer d'arrêter les combats lui
dire bah non du coup on a on annule ce
projet qui est celui qui te tient le
plus avec la réelle politique alors bon
c'est aussi de la rangement c'est vrai
que North stream 2 il y a une prise de
conscience et vous l'expliquez bien dans
Le Rive par rapport au premier pipeline
petite question quand même sur le
sabotage ça reste très mystérieux de
North stream 2 qui n'était d'ailleurs
pas activé alors certains accusent
l'Ukraine on a d'autres accusent Poutine
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez il y a eu
beaucoup de scénarios et d'enquêtes
depuis le début de cette affaire à peu
près tout le monde y est passé il y a eu
on a accusé les Russes les Ukrainiens
les Polonais les Britanniques les
Américains tout ça donc il y a eu des
enquêtes de mes journaux sérieux mais
qui n'apportent aucun élément probant
qui qui ne repose qui sont toutes issues
les dernières du spiggle et du
Washington Post sont issus de l’enquête
allemande avec des éléments concordants
mais dont aucun
n'aboutit à un scénario définitif ce ne
sont que des hypothèses et ce que je
remarque moi c'est que personne ne part
du mauvais postulat parce que personne
ne prend en compte le fait que ce
pipeline c'est pas parce qu'il a été
saboté qu'il est détruit d'abord il a
été saboté à un moment où il était déjà
plus en fonction donc et où personne ne
pensait le remettre en fonction et il en
reste un bout et il en reste tuyau il y
a un tuyau sur quatre qui est intacte et
en plus il faut pas il faut imaginer que
c'est 1200 km dans de tuyaux de de
tuyaux dans la mer Baltique les
infrastructures qui coûtent très cher
sont intactes il y a 20 mètres qui sont
détruits c'est à dire c'est extrêmement
réparable ouais donc évidemment la
possibilité c'était donc un de
l'utiliser reste ça peut être lui ça
peut être
j'expose dans mon livre les hypothèses
je dis qu'il y a des des intérêts
rationnels et ça c'est seulement la
Russie qui a un intérêt rationnel et il
y a des air intérêts passionnés à le
faire et là tout le monde est concerné
donc bon je laisse vous l'aurez compris
c'est absolument passionnant le piège
Nord Stream aussi a le temps avec je le
disais cette plume à la polar mais tout
est vrai c'est une enquête
journalistique signée Marion bonne
rotterghem que je recommande très
chaudement vous restez avec moi c'est
l'heure de nos parties pris les
affranchis vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
bonsoir les affranchis Richard Werly
pour son regard européen vous allez vous
faire vivre d'ailleurs cette campagne
européenne de juin prochain qui est déjà
dans toutes les têtes et puis Yanis
roder avec une nouvelle histoire d'école
vous êtes allé au cinéma pour pour voir
ce film de Thomas littly on en parle
dans un instant on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée c'est vous qui nous
la racontez Stéphanie Despierres bonsoir
ce soir 49,3 saison 2 et cette saison 2
s'annonce un peu différente c'est une
saison où il y aurait comme pour les
chasseurs les bons 49-3 et les mauvais
49-3 c'est en tout cas ce qui essaie
d'expliquer en ce moment le camp
présidentiel alors il y aurait les bons
49-3 sur des textes budgétaires
techniques qui n'enflamme pas beaucoup
l'assemblée et encore moins le pays et
puis il y aurait les mauvais 49-3 comme
celui de l'an dernier évidemment sur les
retraites qui mettent le feu à
l'hémicycle et qui font descendre les
Français dans la rue alors un exemple de
bon 49,3 et bien dès la semaine
prochaine pro probablement puisque les
députés font leur rentrée et elles
pourraient commencer par le douzième
49-3 depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron le gouvernement veut absolument
faire adopter sa loi de programmation de
finances publiques qui avait été
retoquée l'an dernier alors c'est un peu
technique en fait c'est une sorte de
méga budget sur 5 ans qui prévoit de
ramener le fameux déficit sous la barre
des 3% en 2027 alors la gauche n'en veut
pas les républicains n'ont plus alors le
ministre de l'économie se démène pour
les convaincre il a vu des députés LR la
semaine dernière il en revoit cette
semaine mais si il n'y parvient pas et
bien il faudra déclencher un 49-3
il pourrait y avoir un 49-3 dès le début
de la semaine prochaine est-ce que c'est
pas un peu violent
quel est notre objectif aujourd'hui sur
cette loi de programmation c'est de
fixer un cap pour les Français moi je
pense que sur ce sujet il y a pas de
tabou je pense surtout qu'il y a un
tabou dans certains groupes de
l'opposition quand je constate que la
rentrée a été plutôt active très active
pour les républicains avec d'un côté la
moitié du groupe parlementaire qui
demande le sérieux budgétaire absolu et
que de l'autre côté vous avez l'autre
partie du groupe qui demande 15 à 20
milliards d'euros sur la table pour
compenser des mesures pour cette rentrée
j'ai du mal à comprendre quelle est la
position de certains groupes dans nos
oppositions en revanche ce qu'on a
compris c'est que ce 49-3 serait un bon
49-3 selon les critères du camp
présidentiel un haut responsable du
groupe
m'a confié un 49,3 sur ce texte ça ne va
pas m'empêcher de dormir et il fait le
pari ce sera pareil pour les français et
même le président de la Commission a des
finances l'insoumis Éric Coquerel semble
un peu résignée
et sur le papier oui je vois pas comment
on l'évite de toute façon je vais vous
dire chacun sait que l'autre
programmation à distance public n'est
jamais respecté jamais donc tout ça
d'importance quand même modérée c'est
pas grave si un 49-3 parce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit que c'est
ce texte n'a pas l'importance que le
gouvernement lui donne sauf que c'est
une défaite politique pour lui que ce
soit d'ailleurs le vote compte ou un
49-3 ce qu'il admettra une fois de plus
qu'il a pas la majorité ce qui reste une
petite fenêtre pour que le gouvernement
soumette ce texte vote oui toute petite
suggéré par le rassemblement national
par Jean-Philippe Tanguy le monsieur
finance publique du RN qui dit que son
groupe pourrait s'abstenir alors dans ce
cas là ça peut permettre à la loi de
passer 149,3 mais cette solution
n'enchante pas du tout une partie des
députés Renaissance qui ne veulent
surtout ne rien de voir ORL c'est
évident si à 49-3 c'est quand tout de
suite dès que ça commence ou un peu plus
tard pas lundi mais le mercredi puisque
le débat sur la loi de finances
publiques commence le mercredi soir à
21h30 là il y a ceux qui veulent
dégainer la carte immédiatement pour
passer à la suite de l'agenda et puis il
y a ceux qui veulent discuter quand même
quelques heures mais quoi qu'il en soit
sous 49-3 sera certainement le début
d'une longue série comme l'an dernier
puisque faute de majorité la première
ministre devra l'activer une dizaine de
fois d'ici fin décembre si elle veut
faire budget voter par voter le budget
évidemment merci beaucoup pour ce
décryptage Stéphanie Despierre le roi le
roi Charles III on n'a pas encore parlé
du roi il faut quand même le faire avec
vous Richard il est arrivé il a descendu
les Champs-Élysées il est en train de
dîner en grande pompe à Versailles on
aimerait bien être une petite souris
mais on n'y est pas il sera demain
devant le Sénat c'est l'Européen Charles
III qui vous intéresse ce soir Antibes
exit vraiment my god Myriam vous iriez
jusqu'à insinuer que le trait neutre
souverain britannique va aborder le
divorce de son pays avec l'Union
européenne depuis le référendum du 23
juin 2016 mais c'est vraiment choqué
parce qu'il faut rappeler que le roi ne
dispose ni de sa parole ni de ses
déplacements son voyage qui avait été
reporté en mars vous savez pour des
raisons de manifestation contre la
réforme des retraites il a dû être
approuvé par le Premier ministre Richie
sunac or l'actuel locataire du 10
Downing Street est un brexitter de la
première heure pour le chef du
gouvernement qui est d'origine indienne
l'important c'est le Global Britten
c'est à dire un Royaume-Uni mondialisé
alors vous imaginez le mot brexit sans
le soufre dans la famille royale si
Charles III devait le commenter ici en
France ce serait une bombe atomique pour
les Windsor donc motus et bouche cousu
kips island your Majesty ben
effectivement c'est tout à fait ça sauf
que l'Europe existe et elle est dans les
gènes de cette famille royale le père de
Charles III ne l'oublions pas été né
Philippe de Grèce et de Danemark les
Windsor sont des sacs-co-bourg Gotha une
des plus vieilles familles
aristocratiques allemande et l'on se
souvient que la reine Elizabeth en juin
2007 2017 pour son discours du Trône qui
avait suivi le référendum sur le brexit
un chapeau bleu à fleurs jaunes
c'est-à-dire les couleurs du drapeau
européen bref Buckingham Palace est tout
sauf un bastion europhobe et Charles III
n'est sans doute pas fâché de la
descente aux enfers de Boris Johnson
kirstarmer le leader travailliste de
l'opposition était à Paris lundi il
appelait des pour un nouvel accord entre
Londres et Bruxelles le sunac est
d'ailleurs assez d'accord le Premier
ministre britannique en disant que le
Royaume-Uni n'a pas quitté l'Union a
quitté l'Union européenne mais qui n'a
pas quitté l'Europe bref la politique ne
change pas la géographie ce que la
famille royale britannique c'est
parfaitement depuis le 25 décembre 1066
ce jour-là Guillaume duc de Normandie
monté sur le trône à Westminster vous
voyez l'Europe traversait déjà la Manche
Les chute merci Richard verli elle vous
parle cette chronique c'est ça va
revenir cette négociation sur le brexit
vous y croyez il prend un peu ses rêves
pour des réalités kirstarma il y a des
il y a un progrès de la part de le
candidat a travaillé candidat a
travaillé ce qui sera probablement le
premier ministre britannique c'est que
le brexit était un mot il ne voulait
même pas en parler il ne voulait même
pas parler des des effets négatifs du
brexit et il s'était fait d'ailleurs
maurigéner par une partie des des
antibes-exiteurs de du parti Leiber
quand il avait dit il faut faire réussir
le brexit et autres mais il y a pas de
réussite du brexit il faut abolir le
brexit donc il a déjà fait un progrès en
disant qu'il fallait se rapprocher avec
l'Union européenne mais là il prend un
peu ses rêves pour des réalités c'est
que pour renégocier l'accord du brexit
il faut que Bruxelles et les États
européens les dirigeants européens en
étant vie on a mis quatre ans à négocier
un accord on va pas commencer à le
rebricoler pour les beaux yeux de
kirstar vous reviendrez pour nous en
parler on a envie de vous entendre
davantage alors un métier sérieux le
vôtre Yanis roder c'est aussi le titre
du film de Thomas lilty que vous êtes
allé voir en salle vous allez en plus
voir des films sur l'école alors que
vous passez votre temps dans les classes
oui j'aime bien les films de Thomas
Lilti Myriam alors j'ai voulu voir ce
qu'il dit sur l'école Jerry jaunes quand
le principal de collège accueille
l'excellent vin la cause je ne
contractuel par un très contemporain
c'est déjà une chance pour les élèves
d'avoir un professeur de mathématiques
d'ailleurs on y voit un groupe de profs
dans ce film solidaire dans leurs
différences que quand de bons acteurs
preuve dans les situations personnelles
sont parfois compliquées dans le
déclassement social saute aux yeux alors
quel est le quotidien des enseignants
qui ont montré on les voit enseigner on
les voit se remettre en question penser
repenser leur cours mais aussi douter et
parfois souffrir souffrir parce que un
prof seul face à une trentaine n'a pas
le droit à l'erreur il doit être présent
occuper l'espace occuper la scène en
permanence la solidarité du groupe vient
ici casser cette solitude mais cette
solidarité n'existe ni tout le temps ni
partout puis on les voit préparer un
voyage scolaire on les voit prendre en
charge le protocole anti attentats ils
sont multitâches ses profs et personne
ne leur dit vraiment merci ou presque en
tout cas pas l'inspectrice qui vient
voir la touchante Louise Bourgoin alors
on sent que ça vous a plu vous êtes
reconnu comme prof d'histoire on sait
que vous enseignez en Seine-Saint-Denis
travers ce film alors on pourra toujours
trouver des choses qui ne collent pas
mais oui il m'a plu il m'a plu parce
qu'il n'a rien de caricatural il n'y a
ni le fameux prof Sauveur je vais être
un peu jaloux ni le collège de banlieue
où enseigné relèverait du combat de
catch ni de projets miracles qui
mèneraient des élèves en perdition vers
la lumière ici ce collège lambda de
banlieue visiblement mixte tout est
normal en quelque sorte il ne se passe à
rien de particulier et en fait il se
passe beaucoup de choses et pour vous
dire la vérité Myriam il m'a même ému ce
film car les convictions ils dévouement
des enseignants sont palpables et
sincères je pense que le film sonne
juste il m'a renvoyé à la solidarité que
je connais assez preuve que je croise
tous les jours que font que l'école
fonctionne qui croit même s'ils disent
parfois le contraire et qui partout
œuvre à ce que leurs élèves s'élèvent ce
film a touché parce qu'il montre aussi
les enseignants qui essaient qui
hésitent sur les méthodes éducatives
aussi entre compassion exigences et
bienveillance et parfois échoue il m'a
ému car ses profs n'oublient pas que
n'oublie jamais que les élèves sont des
enfants il m'a ému enfin parce qu'ils
montrent combien ce métier est
profondément humain par les liens tissés
au sein de l'équipe pédagogique mais
aussi et surtout entre le professeur et
ses élèves cette alchimie que vous
n'apprenez pas à l'école des profs à une
époque ou nombre de jeunes sont en
recherche de sens ce film montre combien
ce métier en a alors oui ce métier est
sérieux et ce film est un beau film et
bien cette émotion vous la faites passer
dans votre carte blanche il y a un
escroder ça vous parle parce que je
crois que votre père est enseignant
professeur d'histoire il est mort
maintenant mais il était enseignant
professeur d'histoire et puis j'avais
écrit un livre il y a bien longtemps
avec un jeune professeur
aussi dans une banlieue difficile qui
qui s'appelait Homer et Shakespeare en
banlieue et c'était un professeur qui
faisait faire du grec travailler au
maire et jouer du Shakespeare à des
élèves et il les élevait de manière
extraordinaire bah écoutez on peut
encore voir ce film de Thomas Lutti un
métier sérieux dans toutes les bonnes
salles de l'Hexagone on s'arrête là
merci à vous c'est la fin de cette
émission merci les affranchis le piège
Nord Stream c'est à dire aux éditions
Les Arènes de Mario vendre tergame merci
de nous avoir suivi très belle soirée
pour voir ou revoir cette émission les
réseaux lcpn.fr ou la chaîne Youtube de
LCP à demain
[Musique]